[拍手]
私は子供の頃から自分の考えがあり意見をはっきり言う
子供でした
例えばお正月などで家族や親戚で集まっても自分はまだこんなにちっちゃいのに
大人に交じって何か正しいことがあったら平気で意見を言う子供でした
まだ子供なので大人からは煙たがられていました
親戚の中で私には2つ年上の男性のいとこがいました
彼だけは私が彼よりちっちゃい
みんな大人つまりで私だけまだ子供なのに意見を言っても平等に受け入れてくれました
そのいとこだけが私のことも平等に対等に扱ってくれ
彼はいつでも相手のことを最初に考える人でした
身内ではありますが私もまだ子供でしたが彼のことを本当に憧れ尊敬していました
こういう人を人格者って言うんだな
こういうリーダーになりたいなぁと思っていました
その男性の従兄弟は大学に入ると山岳部に入り本格的に山登りを始めました
ある時山岳部の活動でみんなで山登りをして後輩と1本の材料をつないで崖を登ってい
たときのことです
誰か一人犠牲にならないと全員が滑落する事態に陥りました
私の従兄弟は自らないしで進んで滑落し
それと引き換えに後輩全員の命を救いました
後輩たちは全員無傷で今でも社会で活躍しています
この知らせを聞いたとき私は本当にショックを受けました
私だったらどうしただろう
その時高校3年生だったんですけれども私自身は大学に進学して授業を受けていても
社会に出て働いていても
あの人だったらどうしたんだろうこの人だったらどうしたんだろう
そういうことばかり考えるようになりました
これがわたしにとってのリーダーシップの原点です
あなたならあなたが犠牲になってその代わりに仲間みんなを救うことができますか
それともあなたはやっぱりあなた自身が助かりたいので
あなた以外の誰かがあなたのために犠牲になってくれるのを待つのでしょうか
リーダーシップという言葉を聞くと皆さんどんな人を思い浮かべますか
なんかこう偉い人でしょうか
上司ですか
社長でしょうか
それとも6丁ですか
大臣ですか
それともなんかこうみんなをまとめて引っ張っていく班長のような存在でしょうか
リーダーシップは主にアメリカで貼っかつした概念でもともとは political
リーダーシップ政治的リーダーシップという言葉の略です
ですからリーダーシップは政治とはとても縁があります
どういうことかというと
みなさん普段いろんなルールの中できてますよね
それでそのルールに何なにかしらの歯がゆさを感じたことはありませんか
ルールはあるときみんなで決めるものですが私たちの日常生活は毎日どんどん進化して
いきます
そうするとどうしてもルールというのは私たちの日常生活より
時代遅れになりがちです
私たちはいろいろなルールの中で暮らしていますがそのルールの中の一番乗員あるもの
が法律です
ルールは皆で決めますが
法律はあなたが選挙で選んだ国会議員が国会で法律を決めます
ですからあなたが専門とする分野
それをよっ突き詰めてよりよくしようと思えば思うほどルールや法律を改正したくなり
法律を改正したくなるから国会議員になりたくなります
これが本来のリーダーシップの原型です
私は20代の頃東京に住んでいてさまざまなボランティア活動に夢中になっていました
そのうちどの団体でもリーダーシップ担当役員をするようになりました
週末になると毎週地方に出かけ
地方の支部のリーダーたちにリーダーシップ研修をしました
そのリーダーシップ傾斜を受けるのは大抵の場合1方の名刺
地元のリーダー中小企業の社長御札やっている人たちでした
当時の私はまだ若くまだ20代の女性で海外帰りでした
リーダーシップ研修をすればするほど
反感を買いました
本当にチホンは
駅に降り立ってそこで研修をその街で研修をしたりするので親切な方は朝は新幹線の駅
まで迎えに来てくださるんですよね
ただあそのリーダーシップ検証1日終わって夕方になるとふっかり心を閉ざしてしまい
ぽえをかけても口も聞いてくれず
挨拶もしてくれず帰りには新幹線の駅まで送ってもらえなかったそういうことが何回も
ありました
悔しくて悔しくてたまりませんでした
先輩達に言われた通りのリーダーシップ研修を地方でしてるとに本当にどんどん
どんどん嫌われていくんです
毎週末東京に戻る新幹線や飛行機の中では私はハンカチを口の中にギュッと詰めて
鳴き声が漏れないようにして悔し泣きをしていました
本当に悔しい経験でした
なぜそんなに反感を買ったのでしょうか
私もまだ20代だったので一方通行な
マニュアル通りの研修しかできなかったのかもしれません
また日本ではこういうピラミッド構造の上のほうに20代の女性がいるのは目障りだっ
たかもしれません
でもボランティア活動やコミュニティ活動において
性別や年齢そういうの関係あると思いますか
あなたが見た私の性別や年齢
あなたとの年齢差ではなく私があなたに何を伝えようとしているのか
そこに集中してもらえなかったのは本当に悔しいと思いました
世間では今見ている人の性別や年齢で相手を見下す人もたくさんいるんだっていうこと
が気がつきました
その時私まだ20代だったんですがもし私が中年の男性で
とても業績があり社会的チームあったらあの人たちは peko peko peko
peko 御祀りしていたかもしれません
2012年に
japanese women free だーしフィニッシュアティ部
jwl 愛という女性リーダーシップのプログラムでボストンに1ヶ月間留学しました
最終日に適性検査の結果を知らされたんですがそのときに言われました
あなた国会議員に向いてますよって
もう本当にびっくりしました
あなただったらどうしますか
日本の女性がいきなり国会議員に向いてるって言われてもあなたの普段の生活と
かけ離れていてどうすればいいかわかりませんよね
加えて日本には謙虚検挙や謙遜という美徳があり
彼に女性が私ってすごいんです
って思ったり入ったりしたら社会から反発を買います
pp をわきまえ相手を選んでいっても
君ね自分で自分のことすごいって言ったら終わりだよと言われるのがオチです
だからといって世間体を気にしてせっかく自分が持っている能力や適性を社会に発揮し
ない
これもなんだか逃げているようにも思いました
能力や適性は
あなたがやりたくないからといって
やらなくていいってそういうもんではありません
もしあなたがやりたくないからってあなたの都合で止まりの誰かにあげたり病院行って
手術であなたの能力や適性を誰かに属したりすることはできないんです
適性がある能力がある
そしたらそれを社会にまっすぐ発揮して社会の役に立つ
そうでなければ社会的損失になります
あなた個人の都合ではないんですよてそのときに言われました
ここまで話し合って考えが至ったとき自分が国会議員に向いてるという適性を認めまし
た
自分は国会議員に向いているんだ
そして日本でも男女平等ぐげーしたい
そう考え2017年秋
今からちょうど1年ほど前私は衆議院議員選挙に出馬しました
衆議院選挙でたのすごいでしょと言いたいわけではありません
ライブ長い時間かかってしまいましたが自分の適性を認め
逃げずに実際に自分で行動に移した
この点においてはすごいと言いたいです
この最後の一歩というか次の段階の最初の一歩というのはあなた犯人にしか踏み出せ
ません
誰も代わりに踏み出すことはできないんです
リーダーシップにもジェンダーの違いが潜んでいます
今お話しした私が適性があるにも関らずぐジグジグジグジグジグジグジグ二時間ばかり
かけていて決断をしなかったのは
これ女性ならではの典型的な体験です
あくまでも一般論ですが男性は自己肯定感が高く女性は低いと言われています
実際に私自身も若い女性をリーダーにするときには心からハメたたえ
自己肯定感を高め自信を持たせていました
しかし肝心な自分自身をのことはなかなか認めようとせず自分で自分を褒めるって言う
ことを恥ずかしくてできませんでした
より高いものを求める人は自分に本当に厳しいです
しかし自己肯定感がないということは地震つまり自分を信じることができず結局は
リーダーシップを発揮するには至らないのではないでしょうか
自分の適性を認め逃げずにそれを行動に起こす
実際に行動すると認める勇気
逃げない強さ
これはほかのどのリーダーも意外と思っていないことも分かりました
また自分の力を認めず逃げていた時には今からちょっと客観的になって考えると自分
に注目していて自分がかわいくて自分が中心でした
実際に一歩振り踏み出し乗り越えた今は社会を基準に物事を考えることができるように
なりました
あなたもライバックを卒業してこれから社会で活躍するでしょう
どの分野でも突き詰めればその分野をよりよくしたくなり
それは自然とリーダーシップを発揮するということにつながります
その際に
日本の伝統的な美徳である喧騒や検挙もとても大切なんですが
一方であなたの力を認め逃げずに
社会の役に立っていただきたいと思っています
もうこれ以上ためらうのはやめましょう
ガラスの天井という言葉がありますがこのガラスの天井
壁を作っているのは実はあなた自身なのではないでしょうか
あなたあなたにストップをかけていませんか
社会の役に立ちたいけれど
自分の大切なんです
と私に耳打ちをする人もいます
私のいとこや私が辿った心のプロセスをよく分析すると
を法を乗り越えるという瞬間があります
を法を乗り越えて社会のために尽くすその1年であって自分が大切だからこそ周りの人
も大切で相手も同じくらい大切でその気持ちがを法を乗り越えて
社会の役に立つという行動につながるのではないでしょうか
[拍手]